When I had pneumonia and COVID, I was taken off
eye breaths for three weeks and the doctor started to be back
out of nine days ago. Last Thursday, I started having back
pain and some shortness of breath that was in the ER, this
morning from the pain. The doctor says it has nothing, it's
not from the eye breaths, but I didn't have this pain for a week
or more before I started back up on the eye breaths. I'm
taking clear information, any suggestions. Whenever you have a
reaction to any drug, it's always good to google that drug and
see if the side effect that you're having is listed in their
side effect things. So whatever you watch a commercial about a
drug and then they have to have somebody that is can speak
400 words a second, give you a, you know, disclaimer of the
drug afterwards, which is saying all these things and they say
even death, that means understand again, that means that when
they tested that drug and they said, you know, to 30
different universities to test that drug on 100 patients each,
that drug caused those symptoms in the best studies that they
published. So when they do a drug, they do drug testing, they
do drug testing, they have to get these tested on human
needs. And they send them out to multiple universities to do
test Sun. And then let's say they sent them out to 30 universities
and 28 of them had negative results and two of them had good
results, they have the choice to not publish the 28 negative
results, so nobody ever sees them. And they only publish the two
with positive outcomes, but they have to publish, they have to
publish all the negative data as well. So if somebody died from it,
it was on the positive results table. So not to say it shouldn't take the
drug, let's say that, but it should be aware of a side effect
something. So what else to do for the inflammation? Clear
inflame is a great product for inflammation because it has a
lot of the flavonoids in there. But it's, you know, you have to
take a lot of them. That's the only negative. But this is just
no other way to get around it. So you certainly could add some
tumeric to your shake. Any way you could get into inflammatory
products in your body, you know, using curfew theory, using
the clear inflame, this up the dosage is big time on those things.